Now we're going to talk about oracles.
We really probably have deferred this topic for too long.
Oracles are extremely important for random testing
because if you don't have an automated oracle--that is to say,
if you don't have an automated way to tell if a test case did something interesting--
then you've got nothing.
And in fact, Richard Hamlet in his sort of well-known article on random testing
said that "random testing has only a specialized niche in practice
"because an effective oracle is seldom available."
And this is something that I don't actually agree with.
What we're going to see is that sometimes you have to use some imagination,
but really, there are potentially quite a few oracles available
and that almost always we can make something work
even if it's just a weak oracle like watching out for crashes.
So what I'm going to do is organize the oracles that are suitable for random testing
into a collection of categories.
So we're going to start off with weak oracles.
Weak oracles are some of the ones that are most useful in practice,
but I'm calling them weak because they can only enforce fairly generic properties
about the software under test.
The most important weak oracle is just detecting whether or not
the application crashed.
What a crash usually really means is that the system under test
violated some rule that the hardware imposed like, for example,
memory accesses have to be aligned,
or that the operating system imposed like, for example,
the application isn't allowed to try to write to memory that's owned by the kernel,
and in response to this violation, the operating system has decided to terminate the process
in which the software under test is contained.
The second most useful weak oracle is violation of a programming language rule.
In Python, if you try to access an element of a list that's out of bounds
and if you don't catch the resulting exception,
then your Python program will get terminated.
That's an example of the violation of a language rule killing an application
and serving as an oracle that tells us basically that something went wrong.
And basically, most any programming language has a number of rules like this
and the stronger those rules are, the more effective of an oracle
the programming language runtime can serve as.
And one of the reasons why C and C++ applications crash so much
is because the language is an extremely weak enforcer of runtime rules,
and so basically, all of the enforcement falls upon the operating system
and the hardware itself.